last week I had one of the highlights of
my career I thought it was a great
moment I was on an episode second
episode of barstool Van talks and what
this is is it's a van where two guys big
cat and PFT show up and they ask you
questions Scott Van Pelt was the first
one they went to the mothership did the
interview with with Scotty and I thought
it came off well and then I get episode
two and then all of a sudden I see where
bar stool van talks got canceled and the
episode that I'm on was gonna air
tonight or is it tomorrow morning at at
1:00 a.m. on espn2
big cat Dan cats former co-host of
barstool van talks who joins us now what
the hell happened here so I spoke with
John skipper directly yesterday and he
said he can deal in bar stool he can
deal with the internal pushback but he
can't deal with Dan Patrick so he said
that was a bridge too far and then he
canceled it
so I was the series finale huh
yeah that's obviously a joke he didn't
actually do that okay you know no I
think they were okay with you coming
sneaking in the back door like we said
it's we're still gonna run the interview
on our podcast pardon my take and it's
funny because we had moments where I
think you know we alluded to the fact
that when you get cancelled at any time
those moments aren't very funny I'm
amazed that you got this far with
barstool van talks with the mothership
absolutely shocked and I think I even
said this to you and I think you wanted
that the better that you know the little
that I said was better because you
didn't want to alert management here so
that's that this is legacy stuff
barstool van talks is dead it's over
with sad one one Episode one episode you
can kind of ride off we can make jokes
forever that's the thing is we're guys
who like to make fun of ourselves and
you can't really make fun of yourself
more than having a show that gets
cancelled after one single episode but I
think this is a good thing for you guys
believe it or not
it's it's so I think in the long term
there's there's a difference in a long
term I'm not worried about what we're
going to be because the numbers speak
for themselves and I think there were
probably some people inside ESPN who
were mad for various different reasons
one of which maybe
hey we should we deserve a show I think
the numbers speak for themselves our
podcast what we built at barstool has
been you know growing and growing
growing and there's audience there that
we've cultivated that is in the nut you
know you can't deny what we have done
but in the short term it obviously hurts
a lot and it's you know I shouldn't feel
embarrassed I feel embarrassed because
you know your friends your family
everyone who supported you all these
years is they're very excited for the
debut and very excited for the
opportunity and then boom it's gone in a
second so the short term it really
stinks and we put a lot of effort into
it put a lot of time and you know we
would have preferred to do the 20
episodes instead of just the one was my
episode better than Van Pelt's which is
really all I care about
hmm I would say your episode was dim
your episode was more contentious you do
not let us as much as Scott did I think
that's because Scott ins got down over
the years with our tactics where as you
play on a puncher's chance next time
when we come in an interview again
you'll know to just kind of roll over
like a dog yeah I wasn't gonna do that
and by the way I thought PFT was like
Silent Bob and he didn't say anything
and then all of a sudden he put the
hammer down right away he did he does
that people people people underestimate
us because you know I got the fat guy
mustache look at CSDs of sunglasses and
long hair so that usually works or a
favor we people will come in and when
we're interviewing someone's big no not
you because that's not you but you know
other people big and up note they'll
oftentimes be kind of taken aback and
loosen him up by just our look how
ridiculous well it was an honor to be on
the last episode of barstool Van talks
and you know cross past LP FTA I'll buy
him a couple beers at Woody's in in the
city okay absolutely and like I said
your
you're still running so we'll just have
it all part of my tape no visual well
you won't get the the look of
disappointment in the Dan that's for
putting you in that situation putting
you in a van with the two of us I did
weren't their cup checks at they we had
some cup checks at the end as I was
getting ready to leave we did that's
really what it comes down to it the
other day we enjoyed making something
new and something different and trying
to evolve what we do and that's really
the disappointment is that we thought we
were going to be doing side you know the
fighting on the internet that's not
really been our style ever we want to
just make people laugh and this was
gonna be something that made people
laugh but we'll find something else yeah
you guys paid the price of a couple of
things I think and that's the shame
because you know the show itself should
have been able to stand alone but you
know it was fun and you know we'll cross
paths maybe ESPN Classic could air
barstool van Talks see that some station
step up and do a marathon a barstool van
talk and just play one episode on a
Sunday afternoon could they do a thirty
four thirty on barstool van talks both
episodes behind the footage what happens
just keep replaying some of the footage
but I think we could squeeze you know
maybe a five minute documentary out of
it it would be an electric documentary
I'm all for it I like I like that you
know what maybe I send Tom Rinaldi out
there to do a story on the death of
barstool van talks he brings a piano and
it's very somber tears we got something
here I'm gonna make something I'm gonna
put a smile on your face all right I'm
gonna make you smile today is what I
mean that's my goal today big cat there
we go
I like it we'll get the tear jerker
stuff I think I think we got something
there all right now tell PFT to bite me
thanks so much guys
that's big cat Dan cats former host a
barstool van tucked I had no idea what
I've getting myself into like literally
getting myself into the van and then all
of a sudden I sit down I think I got
Silent Bob and he's not saying it
next thing I know he's pouncing on me
and like they didn't tell you when they
were rolling when they started no we're
rolling
we started I thought we started and then
ago we weren't rolling I said are you
kidding me that killed right there
there's some fun stuff yeah yes I'm
pretty upset the cup checks aren't gonna
make it to oh man they should just put
the video up on their website and run it
sure they well yeah but the cup checks
were great cuz I got out of the van and
you know I mean they piled on they went
at me pretty hard and so we got out
there like they want to be cheery
they're like hey come on we're buddies
you know once you stick around they got
me a great gift and then all of a sudden
PFT was standing next to me I gave him a
cup check ya see would you rather be the
one that didn't make it or the one that
did hmm
I think I'd rather be the one that
didn't make it because I've already had
two people in the industry to say what
did you say Oh baby talk and I say I
didn't bring this down in all honesty I
was sitting there listening to it you
guys talked about your exit from ESPN
but even if the ESPN executives saw the
interview you did there was nothing in
there that was you know this had nothing
to do with that this was the the women
at ESPN responding of how are we having
this on given what they've said about at
least one of our anchors and it's the
website not the show they're very funny
they're very quick and they double-team
you so I'm bookended by big and they're
spreading out their legs are wide open
like I'm you know like shrunk like
trying to you know squeeze into this
back seat of the van PFT those sneaky
sneaky long and then big cat yeah they
came after me he's medium shirt oh yeah
he got a smedium shirt on fake mustache
but they were fun it was good but never
see the light of day on espn2 they were
so proud on ESPN to like you guys are
sellouts you're on espn2 what are you
doing you don't want to be on espn2 for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]